obviously Christine your name is
synonymous with playboy but right now in
the last few years you have become
chairperson of Canyon Ranch when I think
about what Canyon Ranch has done it sort
of changed the travel business for women
before we had Canyon Ranch men were
taking ski trips golf trips fishing
trips women weren't what is it saying
about women being independent what does
it say about their discretionary income
well I think you're right when Canyon
Ranch started in 1979 it was a
trailblazer in many regards first of all
the whole idea of a destination healthy
vacation but also a place where women
could go and one of the most popular
ways that women go there are in groups
or mother-daughter gatherings I took a
group of corporate women who are part of
women corporate directors and we did a
mix of Canyon Ranch access to
practitioners around healthy living and
our own meetings about getting more
women on boards and it is true that it
is both about taking power over your own
health but also having the discretionary
income to say I need to do this for
myself and do you think in the last ten
years there has been a shift more women
have said I have the money I'm going to
make the time I'm going to do this for
myself because then the 1970s 1980s we
didn't see it happening I do think so
although there is still that pressure
that women as the ultimate multitaskers
feel to do it all and therefore the need
to actually decompress so I think we
always feel a little guilty about taking
time for ourselves and yet whether it's
from the perspective of being a mother
and being the doctor mom in the family
and knowing that it starts with taking
care of yourself or whether it's from
the point of view of making sure that
you're in touch with what are the newest
trends and what's most reliable about
health and wellness women are really the
gatekeepers how about for you what
prompted you to take the leap you sat on
top of Hefner enterprises as the CEO for
a number of years you couldn't have
gotten any higher your name is
synonymous with a global brand and you
walked away from that brand why well I
was told when I was leaving that I had
been the longest-serving female CEO of a
New York Stock Exchange company because
I did it for 20
years and my immediate reaction was oh
that just means I did it too long it's a
high-stress job and I felt I had done a
great job of building the brand globally
taking us onto the web taking us into
mobile and I had always wanted to do
something else at some point in my life
and it seemed with the election
President Obama there was a sort of
sense of change in the air you know kind
of if not now when
was it hard for you to make that
branding transition many people look at
playboy clearly as a company that
involves women but many would say it
exploits women and now you're in a
business that absolutely empowers them
are we looking at playboy the wrong way
well I was very proud of the fact that
over 40 percent of my executives when I
left were women that whether it was
women who wrote for the magazine or the
fact that 80% of our licensed
billion-dollar business when I left was
made up of apparel and accessories sold
to women I think it was more a lifestyle
brand than its origins as a men's
magazine but there are certain
similarities oddly between the two they
really were trailblazers in their own
way they were and our lifestyle brands
that kind of created categories strong
founders actively involved real mission
driven organizations with an enormous
sense of pride and a kind of family
culture so I have been on the board of
Canyon Ranch for a dozen years and knew
the people but I think my time at
playboy actually helped me because what
I'm doing for Canyon Ridge is really
extending a brand and content across
media platforms and then doing business
partnerships to do things like Canyon
Ranch meals delivered at home so it's
similar but different
how are you extending that Canyon Ranch
brand as you said meals at home people
think of Canyon Ranch as a destination
they don't think of it as something to
have in their home or to take with them
how are you changing that brand well and
you're absolutely right it hasn't been
heretofore something that you could take
home so what we're trying to do is put
the right partnerships together build
out a robust website offer personal
coaching online that takes the canyon
ranch approach whether it's to healthy
weight or stress and makes it accessible
to people in home taking things like our
food Pro
and making that accessible at home so
that people who aspire to Canyon Ranch
and haven't had the chance to go can
benefit from the extraordinary knowledge
of the doctors and nurses and
nutritionists and exercise physiologist
to build out sometimes you have to shut
down what was the experience like for
you when you were at Playboy and you
said it's time for us to shut down these
Playboy Clubs how do you continue to
build out a brand and make it bigger
while saying I need to cut my losses in
certain areas well I've always believed
actually generally in business that the
things you choose not to do whether that
means closing something down or not
going down a certain path are probably
even more important than the things you
choose to do they're just less visible
to you know the media and to the
consuming public so we were pretty
rigorous about saying what do we want
the brand to represent where is the
intersection of the brand and business
opportunities and you're quite right a
lot of the 80s was made up of getting
out of you know the book club business
and the limousine business and the club
business and the modeling agency
business in order to focus on multimedia
and licensing and for you as you're
considering for Canyon Ranch the
businesses you want to be in one of the
approaches and having Canyon Ranch at
home is that because you're saying some
people in this economy simply can't
afford to have the canyon Ranch
experience so I want to change my brand
to attract more people of a different
price point I wouldn't say it's about
changing the brand I would say it's
about going from a luxury brand to a
premium brand or as the ranch itself
would say sort of democratizing the
brand because it is an expensive
vacation as a result of the high touch
number of experts that you get to have
access to when you're there and yet the
ideas and the power of Canyon Ranch to
give you the tools and inspiration to
lead a healthier life that can and now
will be much more accessible